good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this auspicious event
I'm Ian Shapiro director of the
Macmillan Center and I'm just going to
introduce master of ceremonies today you
know Montero who's going to be
introducing our speaker and and seeing
the event but I did want to say a little
bit about the Stinson ranches themselves
I can't resist just saying about was in
the Kennedy administration and they're
still writing books I don't know who
that is so it's a real treat for us to
be able to listen to him today
the funding for this lecture series came
from an anonymous donor in honor of
Henry Stimson that Yale College class of
1889 an attorney and statesman whose
government service culminated in his
tenure as Secretary of War during the
second world war since nineteen ninety
eight months collaborated to brain
dispense distinguished diplomats and
foreign policy experts to the sent to
the Senate to lecture on their books
that have been published by Yale
University Press previous dim sum
lectures have included political order
in changing societies by Samuel
Huntington arms and influenced by Thomas
Schelling
the Arab Center the promise of
modernization by Marwan washer beyond
the Democratic maze by John Donne what
happened to national liberation by
Michael Walzer the imprint of Congress
by David Mayhew FDR's three hundred days
by Susan Dunn and most recently John
Mearsheimer as liberal ideas
and international realities so as you
can see it's an auspicious list of books
that's only a partial list that have
come out of this lecture series but as
you'll learn in a second from my
colleague Ramon Tyra it's hard to
imagine a more fitting instance the
lecture to join that illustrious list
well as your distinct honored to be here
to introduce some we are folk as the
suitors Henry Stimson lecturer I usually
try to wing these after having read our
lecturers bio I decided it is better not
to so there's a long list of very very
distinguished accomplishments he's a
veteran foreign policy consultant author
and professor mr. Paul taught history
and Arabic language and literature and
helped to found the center for Middle
Eastern Studies at Harvard University
from 1955 until 1961 when President
Kennedy appointed him a member of the
policy Planning Council responsible for
the Middle East Central Asia and much of
Africa during the Cuban Missile Crisis
he served as one of three members of the
crisis management committee during this
period is also asked to become Deputy
Commissioner general of the United
Nations Relief and Works Agency for
Palestine refugees in the near East in
1965
mr. Polk resigned from government
service to become professor of history
at the University of Chicago there he
established the center for Middle
Eastern Studies and was a founding
director of the American Middle Eastern
Studies Association in 1967 he became
the founding director and we the
president at the apply students and
Institute
for Affairs which among other ventures
hosted the 20 foot wash conference only
the weapons and did much of the planning
for the United Nations Environment
Program we're still in the 60s
mr. Paulk was called back to the White
House 1987 Middle Eastern war the Six
Day War to write the draft peace treaty
in to act as assistant to the former
director of the National Security
Council and then the president's special
assistant of george bundy in 1970 at the
request of the Israeli prime minister
golda meir he successfully negotiated
successfully negotiated with President
Nasser of Egypt a ceasefire in the Suez
Canal is the author of many books on
world affairs including the United
States and the Arab world elusive beast
the Middle East in the 20th century
understanding Iraq understanding Iran
out of Iraq with George McGovern and the
list goes on and on I'll just cite my
favorite title Humpty Dumpty the fate of
regime change or more recently his
latest work to be published by
University Press is titled crusade and
jihad the thousand-year war between the
Muslim world and the global war he's
also published widely in foreign affairs
outlets such as point affairs the
planting Harper's The Bulletin of the
Atomic Scientists and Ramon diplomatic
fear not I'm not going to be here all
the time last paragraph mr. Paulk is
here to give three lectures on the broad
theme of America confronts the
post-imperial world today's the first of
these three lectures in today's title is
Snow White's mirror another great title
what we see in what others see or how
both war and altruism shaped American
image of ourselves and set the pattern
on foreign policy the next lecture will
be on Monday of next week and it will be
titled how from our earliest days we
have been beset by fears of violence and
have increasingly put our faith in
military force this is something we
these titles like to Stanley Kubrick and
Wednesday's lecture will be the last
length of the third one is our quest for
affordable world security feasible and
what
can we do to make it more likely I'll
hope you join us again for the lectures
on Monday and Wednesday I hope you join
us today for a reception in mousse all
comments just across from this building
immediately after this lecture and I'm
delighted to introduce I hope this won't
be Humpty Dumpty I have to start by
teasing you all in the 18th century and
before great universities were in good
climates today I think there that is no
longer the case I've my wife and I have
just come from the South of France
to this morally uplifting environment
that you have here and we frozen to
death for the last little while it gives
me great pleasure and it's a great
privilege to be able to talk to you and
to exchange views with you on these
lectures in honor of Henry Stimson mr.
Simpson who was after all a son of Yale
in the long and distinguished career
served the Secretary of War Secretary of
State and once more a Secretary of War
he embodies the theme of the first talk
that I want to discuss with you today
the complexity of the American character
he was a man of peace but he was also
the lord of war as I will emphasize it
was the experience mr. Simpson
exemplifies that has marked our country
from the very beginning and all of what
I'm talking about today has little to do
with foreign policy directly I think
it's my aim is to set the basis on which
we have one way or another approach the
world in the last two centuries what I
want to discuss with you really er in my
three talks or three interlocking topics
that arose from but we're not
the book that I've just had published by
Yale there I talked mainly about
International Affairs and the role of
the north part of the world in impacting
on the South China and Russia and Asia
Western Europe and Britain and Africa
and Asia and eventually America and the
Philippines what I want to do here is to
touch the other side of these issues
that is what formed the American
character what has shaped our approach
to the world why have we done the things
that we've done why have we not done
other things and I ask you to bear with
me as I've emphasized many the
historical background I seems to me that
so much of what we are inundated with
today our spot news piece is something
that happened yesterday and we forget
that today and we don't have any basis
on which to think about these things in
the next day's so what I want to do is
to start more or less at the beginning
of the American experience and run
through a part of it with you today as a
historian I've learned to respect folk
wisdom which is often embodied in in
fairy tales so hence the the idea of of
talking about the the mirror the magic
mirror of Snow White because it seems to
me one of the fascinating things that in
that simple childish story a great truth
was brought out that when we look into a
mirror we see what we really want to see
it Snow White stepmother you remember
looked in and saw the the fairest of
them all and to a large extent every
country does that we Americans
particularly do it
but what I have found interesting is to
think that since it was a magic mirror
we can dicker around with its capacities
to some extent and so I've have
pretended that the other side of the
mirror was a one-way window so that
others look through it and they see our
faces too and the disparity between our
view of who we are what we're about what
we've done in the world and what others
see is a very large part of what is
flowing past us in the media every day
so I will go back to the very beginning
of the experience and mention that just
up the coastline here was the landing of
the Mayflower we don't know very great
deal about that in fact there were many
ships that were named Mayflower and what
we do know though is that the foundation
of the various early colonies in America
were impelled by colonialism the people
who came across the Atlantic came both
to escape the tyranny and the fear at
that time of Europe where Christians
primarily were involved in killing each
other as rapidly and as massively as
they could in the thirty year war on
various other episodes and the pilgrims
who came here were to some extent like
the refugees we see today pouring out of
Africa and Asia into Europe and they
were more organized and they were richer
although they denied being very rich to
come to America because they needed to
find a place where they could establish
themselves and their beliefs and they
formed immediately two interesting
things they gave us the
the first more-or-less constitution of
America and the the Mayflower documents
and they also then said about
establishing the first viable state that
continued the city on the hill was the
the term but what is interesting about
the term the city on the hill is it is a
native Indian word Massachusetts that it
means the city on the hill but of course
the pilgrims didn't want the native
people to stay in the city on the hill
so they were establishing both a new
Commonwealth where they believed they
were doing good and where they were
involved in taking the land away from
the people who were there which is of
course the essence of colonialism as we
know it all over Africa and Asia today
what we didn't know very much about or
at least I didn't as a young student
know very much about it was exactly what
they were trying to do what they ran
into was the local people who owned the
land began to resist and war followed
raid and counter-attack and they often
led the massacres most encounters were
small because the Indian societies were
often small and few loved the sandy
records so what we've tended to see is
the image reflected on our side of the
mirror we've tended to see what people
are ancestors if you will wanted to see
but we have enough records to show the
early history the new world was actually
a chronicle of ethnic cleansing here in
Connecticut on the Mystic River as you
all know the Pequot War of 1636 was
typical of dozens if not hundreds of
encounters that followed in it about 700
Indians virtually the entire male
population were killed
and many more were sold as slaves to
work in Bermuda scores and hundreds of
episodes like that followed as the
British in French did in the other India
the one in Asia our ancestors used rival
Indian nations to fight against one
another and in the French and Indian War
just before the Revolution it was the
Algonquin fighting the Iroquois dividing
and conquering was easy because each
society was an alien to its neighbors
the different societies spoke different
languages or dialects they often had
incompatible customs and frequently
worship different gods as in the other
India each could be used against the
others and citing war among them became
the accepted tactic of colonialism but
over time the British overlords of the
American colonists found these.what may
found these continual Wars expensive and
disrupted so when they were incited by
small groups of the colonists coming in
from Scotland and Ireland and England
primarily the British recognized them as
virtual outlaws and they tried very hard
to stop them from taking more Indian
land
not because they were being particularly
kind to the Indians but because they
were causing trouble and made tax
collection difficult and all the other
problems of government almost impossible
so in 1763 shortly before our Revolution
the British tried to call a halt they
drew a line along the top of the
Allegheny Mountains and ferb and any
movement beyond that by colonists but
geography was against them they didn't
have the means to stop the flow any more
than the Europeans today have been able
to stop the flow of refugees out of
Africa and Asia the frontier moved
inexorably westward to subgroups of
Europeans hacked out the wilderness and
or seize the lands of the Indians who
had already done so our schoolbooks tell
us of our ancestors quest for Liberty
and the American Revolution
and it was a real quest and the books
are right as far as they go
but the British attempt to rescind the
illegal grabs of land along the frontier
in 1774 was one of the causes of course
of the American Revolution even our
great hero George Washington was of two
minds about what we were seeking as he
rode into Indian lands he kept a sharp
outlook for lands the Indians had
already cleared that he could acquire
and he acquired quite a lot of them well
at the same time he excoriated the land
jobbers speculators and scattered as
scattered settlers he was not also as I
mentioned concerned with protecting the
Indians but he was worried about the
Indians ability to fight back what
bothered him was the cost of warfare
there was no question of leaving the
Indians their land but as he wrote I
quote him there is nothing to be
obtained by an Indian war but the soil
they live on and this can be had by
purchase at less expense and without
that bloodshed the first government that
was set up to win independent for quite
America the Confederation was too weak
to enforce a policy such as Washington
wanted the Continental Congress had no
more success in stopping the settlers
and speculators in the British it had
and once the Revolution had been won the
new governments needed Indian land even
more than the previous government or the
British had before thank you ma'am there
were veterans who had to be paid off
with the newly seized Indian lands so
engagements and expulsion followed when
the explosions accomplish their purpose
or where further engagements were too
costly a pause could be made with a
temporary ceasefire or treaty the first
treaty was made during the revolutionary
war with the Delawares
in 1778 and thank you sir
you must be telling me something the the
last treaty was made almost a century
later with the Pierce Nez percé in 1868
in that century our government made 367
treaties with Indian societies but all
these treaties were really just
intervals of calm among the storms of
conflict earlier on in 1788 mr.
Simpson's predecessor a Secretary of War
Henry Knox observed to Congress that the
whitelist settlers I quote him here have
frequently committed the most unprovoked
and not direct outrages against the
Cherokee Indians an open violation of
the Treaty of Peace made by the United
States to such a height as to amount to
actual although informal war and I'm so
flirtatiously stained the American name
however the colonial system lingered on
indeed from the Indian side of the magic
mirror it looked much worse
the major menace to the Indians was not
the federal government which like
Britain before the Revolution was mainly
interested in cutting the cost of
maintaining minimal public security the
almost daily threat to the Indians arose
from the government's and militias of
the former colonies that had become
States their policies and actions were
driven by the settlers who were fighting
their way down the great wagon road into
what they thought of as a wilderness
these settlers were wild Restless people
often scotch-irish
of whom my ancestors for they were the
already established more civilized in
mainly English colonies colonists on
that coast regard to them as just white
Indians as a contemporary Anglican
missionary described them they exposed
themselves often quite naked without
ceremony rubbing themselves and their
hair with bare soil and tying it up
behind like a bunch of Indians but they
were better armed and they usually
outnumbered the
so they won almost every fight the
federal government had bound itself in
the Treaty of Ghent that ended the war
of 1812 to return all the territories
that had been seized from the five
Indian so-called civilized tribes the
creeks the Cherokees the chalk toes the
Chickasaws and the Somalis the Americans
both officials and private citizens
simply ignored the treaty when Andrew
Jackson led military campaigns against
the Indians he practiced what all
colonial governments do like the Russian
campaign against the Chechens like the
Chinese campaign against the Zim
Guardians the French campaign against
the Algerians virtual genocide then when
he became President Jackson introduced a
new element he would Weber today call it
the good-cop bad-cop technique if the
Indians didn't accept the federal good
cop policy they would be faced with the
claims of the bad cops the state
governments who were all language
land-hungry driven by their newly
arrived settlers they each one of them
claimed jurisdiction to be given freedom
to act violently if they wished under
their sovereign character sovereign
character while today it sounds
recondite was then a key political issue
who or what were the Indians were the
nation's well obviously there were
societies were they also States in the
sense that Britain in France and Spain
for example were states and so had a
position in the law of nations the issue
came to focus on the Cherokee people
Cherokees had lived in what became
southeastern United States for time out
of mind of mind the Spanish conquistador
Hernando de Soto encountered them
already in the middle of the 16th
century English colonies colonists in
the Carolinas traded with them at least
but before the end of the 17th century
and in 1711 they became allies of the
British to fight another people and they
signed a peace treaty with United
in 1785 and and another one in 1791 so
they bracketed the American
revolutionary experience in the
formation of the new state around 1800
the Cherokees were thought to possess
53,000 square miles of territory in
Tennessee North Carolina Georgia and
Alabama that was their homeland
but it was also the cause of their
tragedy the terms of the character
Cherokee tragedy were set long before
Jackson's time even before his time as
president Thomas Jefferson indeed began
to think about removing them then in
1817 they were offered a deal the Treaty
of the Cherokee agency proposed a swap
an acre of land on the western side of
the Mississippi for taker of land on the
east Cherokees of course were not
attracted by the proposal they cleared
the land built houses to move they would
have to start all over again
they'd have to drive out the people who
lived on the new lands and a new round
of wars finally they'd come to regard
themselves and the term were used today
or so often as Native Americans indeed
they were far more American and culture
than the scots-irish white Indians
disturbing to the whites as is so often
the case in colonialism is that the
Indians had evolved they had taken
English names created schools similar to
those opened by the white columns and
the settled areas developed civic
institutions much like the whites and
long before the Revolution already in
the 1740s they settled on to become
farmers then as they gradually came to
see what was in store for them the loss
of their homeland the Cherokee tribal
government which had been patterned on
state governments passed a law in 1819
prohibiting any further cessation of
land that's a very typical move as we've
seen in our time of Asian and African
societies to finally in 1827 Cherokee
delegates met
just like our founding fathers had met
40 years before and adopted a
constitution it was modeled on the
American Constitution that act proved
that they liked our finally founding
fathers could actually create a state
and it showed for that further action
they could pass and enforce laws so they
were according to the United States a
sovereign state were they as they
claimed to be or not the United States
government seemed to agree that they
were by making treaties with them but
the issue was then the hardest political
argument in American politics and it
ended up in the Supreme Court where
under the leadership of Chief Justice
John Marshall the court made two
historical decisions
the first decision in 1831 a Cherokee
Nation versus Georgia Justice Marshall
who was not himself a lawyer wrote for
the court that the Cherokees were not a
sovereign nation but were a domestic
dependent nation and could not address
the Supreme Court so the court was not
legally entitled to review their case
one of Marshalls colleagues went further
he maintained the Cherokees from not
even a society but nothing more than
wandering hordes having neither rules
nor government two justices dissented
saying that the having made treaties
with them the federal government had
ruled already that there were states for
my purpose here what was also
significant is that the court was not
aware of any of the similarities between
what was happening in America and what
was happening in Africa and Asia
as powerful societies overwhelmed the
weak on behalf of the court Marshall
wrote that the condition the Indians in
relation to the United States is perhaps
unlike that of any other two people
anywhere in existence is marked by
peculiar and cardinal distinctions which
do not exist elsewhere but in fact as we
know now they all did
in in our time we have focused more on
the Foreign Affairs aspect of this where
we've seen that the wiggers in Asia the
Chechens the Tatars the Indonesians have
Bengalis the Berbers the Arab the
Sudanese and other colonial people who
are unknown to Marshall had had
experiences almost exactly like those of
the Cherokees so there is a unity of
world experience in the issue of
colonialism that we are only I think now
beginning to understand a year later the
court changed the marshal himself then
the court changed his mind and another
case known as Worcester versus Georgia
the court in effect accepted the
Cherokees were a sovereign state
therefore Georgia had no right to
enforce state laws in Cherokee territory
and the Indian Removal Act was illegal
but of course the peculiar relationship
of colonial colonial eyes to the
colonial Azores did exist throughout the
colonial world at that time
one of Marshalls colleagues on the
Supreme Court who had descended in the
first case wrote I quote him thanks be
to God
the court can wash their hands cleaned
the iniquity of oppressing the Indians
in disregarding their rights but not
quite so fast President Johnson was
unmoved as he's alleged to have said
John Marshall made his decision I led
him in forces and of course there was no
way the court at that time could do so
populism at that time was the theme in
American politics as it so obviously is
today regardless is the Supreme Court
Indian Removal continued and became
increasingly violent the Cherokees and
other Indians were driven across the
Mississippi along what became known as
the Trail of Tears of the 15,000 who
were driven out of their homes toward
what is now Oklahoma
4,000 died the horror of their forced
migration was witnessed and described by
a young French visitor to America alexis
de tocqueville he observed it himself
and then he found that it came to haunt
him when later in life he became a
member of the French parliament he would
warn his colleagues in the French
parliament that the price to be paid for
French colonialism in Algeria was
overwhelming
he cut to the quick of the problem of
colonialism in memorable words he said
the social time which distress and long
since weaken is then dissolved the
colonized people have no longer a
country and soon they will not be a
people their very families are
obliterated their common name is
forgotten their language perishes and
all traces of their origin disappear in
America cultural genocide was a process
as practiced later by the French the
Chinese the Russians and the British it
was a carefully orchestrated policy in
fact the Russians in conquering the area
around the south of what is today the
port cities of the Black Sea the
Russians dug up tombstones and
obliterated the markings on them that
had the original languages written on
them
they desperately tried to wipe off the
slate of everything that was a memory of
the past and the French did a very
similar thing in Algiers where in effect
they D nationalized Rd lingua lized
virtually the entire population in
seventeen are sorry in 1873 the American
Commissioner for Indian Affairs wrote
that the United States has in theory
over 65 independent nations within our
borders with whom it is entered trading
relations
as being a sovereign people but he noted
that it ruled them his wards to the
government and his Ward's of the
government the Indians were kept apart
from ordinary that is to say white
citizens we can date the process to
colonial Massachusetts where the
recently defeated Indians were moved
into what we'll call prank towns so they
could be kept under watch that
experience may be taken as the ancestor
of the latest policy letter policy of
moving the Indians into reservations
that performs some of the functions of
ghettos that enclosed the Jewish
community and medieval Europe and the
segregated areas for natives in Africa
and Asia by 1890 there were 162 Indian
reservations in which the Indians were D
nationalized much as the blacks had been
and jumbled together despite differences
in culture or even languages their
status fees of the white Americans was
put in suspension theoretically is
Ward's of the federal government with
limited obligations and privileges they
were being prepared for citizenship but
effectively they were being removed from
American society as the Congressional
Indian Peace Commission noticed noted at
that time when the lands of the Indians
are taken the Indian himself is lost
sight of a parallel policy was to be
adopted after the first world war by the
League of Nations it was a continuation
of the colonial system in Africa and
America under the title of mandates the
inhabitants of the mandates countries
like Syria Iraq particularly Lebanon
were all to be prepared for independence
they were regarded as somehow Ward's of
the mandating governments who were the
old colonial governments simply making
operating under a different name and
they were also in effect lost sight of
just as the Indians had been the last
Indian American war was in 1898 but
memory of the Sentry
the struggle became part of the
mythology of America and was a favorite
subject of the great American University
which is the movies let me confess I
learned my first history from the movies
as a boy riding fences on my father's
ranch in Texas it never occurred to me
that only a half a century before there
were no fences and that my father's
ranch was Comanche territory nobody I
knew at that time knew much of anything
about the Comanches not even their
correct name but from the movies I knew
at least the name of the Apache chief
Geronimo the movie taught me that he was
a vicious terrorist tomahawk in hand
ready to scalp men women and children
scalping how horrible the very essence
of terrorism something that even the
terrorists in our day they don't seem to
try to do well I did not know and would
not have a belief I've believed at that
time was that Texas and other
governments including Connecticut
offered bounties for Indian scalps that
was unthinkable to me as a young boy the
good guys were the Texas Rangers in the
u.s. cavalry as a child I played cowboy
and Indian with all Indians with all my
young friends we knew that the only good
Indian was a dead Indian none of us
wanted to be Indians and even our games
they always the news always lost my
magic mirror reflected only white faces
the face I saw as a young cowboy was as
a member of warring America what we'd
call our teeth doing over the previous
century and here I pick up the second
theme of our national character the
desire to do good John Winthrop borrowed
the theme as he did all of the
regulations of his regime up in
Massachusetts from the Bible
while edicts and social convention to
his community were largely drawn from
the Old Testament and were draconian
complete with hangings burnings and
stoning to death he cast his wider
aspirations in terms
the New Testament for Matthew five as
the great English biblical scholar
William Tyndall rescued from Greek and
put into simple and memorable English
and what we know that is the King James
Bible with review most his most famous
proclamation ye are the light of the
world a city that is set upon a hill and
so he went on to say the light did not
shine beyond Massachusetts it did not
indeed shine for Massachusetts his
Indian neighbors when one of his
followers suggested that ceasing Indian
land was wrong
Winthrop replied that God had given the
pilgrims their title and banished at the
center from the colony but other men of
religion picked up the task successor
church groups gave generous aid not only
to Indians but to peoples all over the
world in the nineteenth century the
American Board of Commissioners for
foreign missions founded schools and
hospitals over much of Africa and Asia
the commissioners were not wholly
altruistic of course they hoped that
what they did would cause the recipients
to convert to their particular brand of
Christianity their activities were
supplemented during the first world war
by privately ministered near East Relief
Society and other government groups and
later on by the Rockefeller Foundation
and its work in China and elsewhere the
aims of these groups both religious and
secular was to share American good
fortune inevitably their activities
created what amounted to a love for
America and gratitude toward Americans
the effect on the American image abroad
was dramatic when President Woodrow
Wilson said about his his crusade he was
greeted not as the head of state but as
a figure totally unknown in
international affairs a messiah Hey
Asians and Africans who did not know
anything about his relief frankly
appalling record on domestic civil
rights virtually worshipped him their
attitudes were not shared by Americans
who read more with his demas
policies and his military invasions of
America's neighbors than his foreign
affairs proclamations his 14 points were
not addressed to Americans Americans
withdrew from their domestic pursuits
first to the fun and frenzy of the
Roaring Twenties
and then into the misery and anger of
the depression in the 1930s American
concern for the world bottomed out the
Second World War changed all that
Americans realized they could not
withdraw from the world so when one
aspect to their new concerned the
government did what no other victor had
done and the generous and farsighted
martial plan they helped the defeated to
rebuild private and semi government
government organizations like care and
scores of national of non-governmental
organizations supplemented and spread
what the government undertook through
aid programs or a mirror like the one in
the fairy tale of Snow White
shows us who is the fairest of us all we
see ourselves we seek peace and
wellbeing for all people we help them
with generous aid to uplift them from
poverty we rush to build when they have
torn things down we rush to assuage
their pains after wars and natural
catastrophes we build nations topple
tyrannies spread democracy and uphold
the rule of law if others don't see
these things they must be myopic jealous
or simply hateful to us it's
increasingly disturbing that numbers of
other people apparently do not see the
image that we see in our mirror worse
we're growing aware that their numbers
are increasing them as I've pointed out
elsewhere when as a young man I traveled
through Latin America Africa and Asia I
was everywhere welcomed today I risk
being shot or perhaps have my head
chopped off by men in many of the same
places this is distressing of course for
me personally and should be alarming for
our nation ultimately it may blowback
against our national security we need
realistically to
examined it rather than to pretend it is
simply wrong so what has happened to
find out look back at earlier times we
know the generous aid was given by
Americans to people all over the world
in the 19th century mainly because
Americans thought it was the right thing
to do
today aid is regarded as a tool of
foreign policy and the attempt to
control other people aid programs were
so loved the American public but
specifically proclaiming these aims in
practical terms each administration
including the two I've worked in
realized they could not get
congressional funding unless the funds
were justified as part of our military
security program altruism was simply
cast aside to talk of helping people
either in the name of God or decency was
a sure way to lose the appropriation the
surest way to get the appropriation but
through was to put in the budget of the
War Department since the recipients
understood our objectives and after all
all they had to do was read the
newspaper to understand it they took the
aid we gave them but they were less
grateful for it than their fathers and
grandfathers had been for private aid
our self-image and other people's
perception was indeed what Snow White's
magic mirror showed on each of its two
sides a different face I now pick up
some White's magic mirror to view
America's first experience in foreign as
opposed to domestic colonialism the
Philippine side of the spanish-american
war that began in 1898 at that time the
US Army was composed of only 16,000
officers and men but as intended in the
Constitution it was backed by state
militias which is it turned out did most
of the fighting the fighting was
America's first foreign
counterinsurgency fortuitously just
before that war broke out a British
officer Colonel later General C Cal well
published a guidebook on colonial
warfare unlike major European Wars
colonial wars were
all and required a new strategy of
counter insurgency the tactics he
advocated have been practiced for years
by Americans against the Indians and by
Europeans in Africa and Asia but they'd
been partially forgotten and Caldwell's
time so he reminded us of them he said
these wars were terrible because they
were people's Wars and they were
virtually unwinnable by regular means
they could last forever so they were as
he wrote what regular armies have mosted
red against guerrillas or insurgency
wrote colonial war must be extremely
brutal it must aim at destroying with
the enemy most values the sanctity of
his home the safety and honour of his
family and his means of earning a living
only if he's completely coward wrote
called well could the colonial rule
become secure as we looked into our side
of the mirror we saw that America was
liberating the Philippines from the
exploitive brutal tyranny of the
previous colonial power Spain it was
against Spain that the Filipinos have
been struggling for independence and
altruistically we wanted to help them so
we disavowed any self-interest President
William McKinley announced that the
American policy was to help the people
of the Philippines achieve independence
and publicly proclaimed and I quote him
again at forcible annexation like other
imperialist nations were doing elsewhere
would be criminal aggression the
philippine insurgents were delighted and
grateful so when the American fleet
defeated the Spanish fleet in Manila Bay
in 1898 they proclaimed a republic and
welcomed the incoming American troops as
Redeemers it was not long however before
relations soured American officials on
the spot regarded the Filipinos as
Rudyard Kipling memorably put it to be
hath devil and half child did they
deserve to be free
could they manage freedom and more
decisively
who was entitled to the fruits of
victory keeping the Philippines was
tempting but people ask themselves was
it really right
President McKinley wasn't sure himself
so he said he sought divine guidance as
he wrote I went down on my knees and
prayed Almighty God for light and
guidance God replied McKinley said take
them all
so McKinley dropped American Filipino
would be friends and worked out a deal
with Spain he bought the Philippines and
by extension the Filipinos for twenty
million dollars peering through their
side of the magic mirror the provisional
government was of course furious the
commander of the American troops wrote
back to his superiors in Washington that
the majority that people were will
regardless with intense hatred of course
he was right bobak came when an American
soldier killed the Filipino soldier that
was the beginning of the Philippine in
quotes insurrection incident followed
terrorist attack and led to Massacre how
to pacify the country was the urgent
question Colonel Caldwell had the answer
like some of the his later successors
who we all had read about he recommended
the use of flying columns as they were
then called they were the ancestors of
Special Forces to strike it once on sign
of trouble by burning their houses
American soldiers most of whom were
middle Western farm boys who joined the
National Guard for a little extra money
or for recreation knew nothing of the
far-off country a contemporary humorist
scoff that the average American had not
known whether the Philippines were
Islands or canned goods the
uncomfortable part time soldiers just
wanted to go home so when they were
attacked by people I didn't understand
they became fearful and angry they
quickly adopted Col Wells advice burning
villages and torturing captives they
were the inventor
a water border boarding nearly drowned
bound prisoners by forcing water down
their throats and they showed their
hatred of the natives by referring to
him and they already familiar Deborah
Tory words as [ __ ] and inventing a
new word for them as GU booze on their
side not having my modern weapons or
military training the Filipinos fell
back on the weapon of the weak terrorism
and guerrilla warfare by 1900 America
had 150,000 of soldiers in the
Philippines in the next two years they
suffered 6,000 casualties while killing
tens of thousands of Filipinos you all
will undoubtedly draw the parallels to
later episodes like this fighting
between the American army and the
insurgents was as bitter as had been the
Wars of extermination against the
American Indians in our eyes bringing
law and order reorganizing society
creating government and hopefully and
ultimately uplifting the people however
much was destroyed or damaged in these
activities were a necessary component of
America's role in bettering the world
and the odds of many non Americans to
the contrary our actions were neither
necessary nor welcomed constantly
repeated surveys of opinions show that
the early Filipinos led what later was
to be called to become a parade of other
peoples many of whom have come to regard
Americans as brutal avaricious and
destructive the contrast between the two
sides of Snow White's magic mirror came
sharply into focus
already in the time of President Woodrow
Wilson I referred to the fact that
Europeans regarded him as a superhuman
figure sent by God to deliver mankind
from the scourge of war but already
before he entered the White House Wilson
had begun to call himself an imperialist
as David fogulson has written no
president has spoken more passionately
and more eloquently about the right of
self-determination yet nope no president
has intervened more often and
on countries while promising to keep
America out of the European war Wilson
sent American forces into Haiti and the
Dominican Republic and twice in New
Mexico by telling Americans that our
invasions were no sense in infringement
of Mexican sovereignty the post-war
intervention he ordered in Russia is
today almost totally forgotten at least
by us and as he cordoned what today we
called dirty tricks to accomplish his
objectives just as he we later tried to
murder Castro and asura and other
figures Wilson had the US government
attempt to poison the Mexican leader
Pancho Villa in domestic affairs we have
to admit that his record was not
attractive he instigated or at least
tolerated attacks on the German American
community on those who opposed as he
himself America's entry into the
European War the critical critics of his
policy the radical left and recent
immigrants yet at the same time he was
carrying out these policies Wilson was
proclaiming his 14 points struggling
against European imperialists who would
divide the spoils of war among
themselves many have charged of course
that he and by extension all of us
benevolent right thinking or at least
right talking Americans down to an
including President Barack Obama are
hypocrites when Wilson was the father of
the League of Nations he didn't prevent
it from turning into a polite white
man's way of carrying white man's
burdens ineffective in Europe the League
of Nations was used to justify
colonialism in Africa and Asia my
reading of American history convinces me
that we were a warring people as I said
war I think we can say see fleece a
fairly say has always been a fundamental
feature of our national culture and from
the beginning we used it time after time
to grow as a nation not only
geographically but also socially and
politically the First World War
integrated the German part of our
society and the Second World War led to
the rebel
that led to our having the first black
president in the White House attitudes
toward war have played crucial roles in
our evolution
they energized our people swept us
across the continent given us a taste of
empire enabled us to overcome powerful
enemies but they've also led to great
wrongs an even greater dangers I suggest
we might think of the machinery of war
as being like a pistol firing it is
sometimes forced upon us but even kept
in the holster it can be used by
ambitious leaders to shape or control
our way of life brought into play it can
threaten or destroy our civic culture
war is not a new challenge to our system
nor is it uniquely American but
controlling it is I believe so urgent an
issue today that we must understand all
of its ramifications as if fully as we
possibly can Americans have never been
willing to see the harsh reality of
intervention and counterinsurgency we
were sure that we went into the
Philippines with the very best of
intentions to bring democracy and modern
habits to a backward people in other
wars as in Vietnam we proclaimed that we
intervene legally at the request of a
constitutive government that protected
against foreign invasion or subversion
where we did not have an invitation as
in Iraq Afghanistan Somalia Libya we
invaded to destroy ugly regimes some
perhaps even all of these regimes
certainly were tyrannies but the
aftermath of our interventions suggests
that the medicine may have been worse
than the disease nor however powerful
the medicine was the disease often cured
war came to see more of a norm than an
exception more of an end than an
acceptable means and more of a patriotic
duty than of a policy to be judged so
who I have we in the last decades moved
from one war to the next with virtually
no pause for consideration there are of
course many reasons that have been put
forward to answer the question
I will try to answer some of them in my
next two talks our founding fathers at
the Philadelphia Convention
Constitutional Convention in 1787
worried about them and tried to create
safeguards for us their deliberations
are the subject of my next talk but
today I leave you with us the stark and
frightening words of a great
practitioner and they are destroyed
societies and states Hermann Goering
famously told his jailers after he could
no longer play a lead role and the game
of Nations how rulers can use Wars he
said and I quote him of course the
people don't want war
why should have some poor slob on a farm
farm want to risk his life in a war when
the best he can get out of it is to come
back to his farm in one piece
naturally the common people don't want
war neither in Russia nor in England nor
for that matter in Germany that is
understood but after all it's the
leaders of the country who determined
the policy and it's always a simple
matter to drag the people along whether
it is in a democracy or a fascist
dictatorship or a parliament or
communist dictatorship voice or no voice
the people can always be brought to the
bidding of the leaders that is easy all
you have to do is tell them that they're
being attacked and denounced the
peacemakers for lack of patriotism and
exposing the country to danger it works
the same in every country war and the
necessary component militarism as
growing sod is the trump card in the
game of power politics he was not
interested in the other side of Snow
White's magic-mirror
but the men who founded our country had
a different view and took upon
themselves a different task however
protect our country from the dangers of
militarism and the terrible cost of wars
so on my next talk I will turn to them
thank you all very much
[Applause]
complexion sniffing thank you very much
for the one selection all the next time
for some questions I would just ask you
to identify yourself and speak Bob
altruism but didn't get oh sorry I
should warn you I'm well I tried to
comment on that pretty fully that seemed
to me that that we need to be very were
that we see only one side generally and
our media of course doesn't help us very
much in doing that I think the the the
general attitude of my generation
growing up was that we were of course
right about everything we were doing
when I was a young man I was too young
to get immediately into the war so I
enlisted in a military training program
to make possible my jumping in a minute
I could be legally accepted into the
army we we all thought that we were
worldwide crusade and I think in the
second world war the
some major justification for that but
exceptionalism it seems to me with what
I was trying to say is that we there is
a unity in world history that I as a
historian are particularly sensitive to
so then when we talk about colonialism
it isn't really different if we talk
about what we did to the Indians and
what the French did to the Algerian so
they're Russians did the Chechens or the
Chinese did the distant guardians are
the dust into the Indonesians it's all
of a pattern and there's nothing
exceptional about it yes sir you
mentioned that centuries of internet
site warfare they would practice in the
mentality of killing each other
and while on this side of the Atlantic
the Indians that had those same
centuries practicing with you know a
sort of modus vivendi creating perhaps a
different kind of mentality so is the
mentality created in us Europeans and
European Americans the Varden way of
seeing the world infused with those
centuries of conflict while I don't want
to idealize
- but they had less we then all you hear
that everybody with me
I I would say I don't disagree with what
you just said I think that it's possible
that one group of people at one time may
be less violent than others but I will
quote in my next lecture if you will
come back again the exchange between
Einstein and Freud on that very question
in exchange they had that was called by
war and the feeling I think that they
come to God and I have pretty welcome to
myself is that all of us are very deeply
flawed animals white black yellow red
whatever Christian Muslim do Buddhists I
thought for a while the Buddhists were
better but I've been painfully brought
to realize that they're part of all of
us and the issue it seems to me that we
come out of in studying history is to
recognize these problems and to try to
find ways in which we can ameliorate
them to the largest possible degree and
create as open and free societies as we
can possibly afford to do I don't think
there's a final cure and maybe it's not
even a good idea to have a final cure
maybe maybe we need as as human beings
the incentive of trying all the time to
do something better than we've done if
we lived in this society where in effect
everything was stopped I think I would
not be very happy yes sir
or do you sorry you want to call on so
you set up a lot of fun Olympic blocks
and dynamic Filipinos I'll view
Americans in one way and normal
rank-and-file American soldiers view the
world in another way than the elites in
this way and the dynamics American
colonial dynamics were the same as as
other countries I was wondering if how
much barians who account for in this
like whether it's worth drawing
comparisons between some of these
experiences so two examples quickly
I was the soldier and the one I saw was
not in line with with the description of
American soldiers and then secondly on
the Philippines for example the
Philippines in World War two was the
only country that immediately started to
assist the Japanese when they came all
other liberated colonies by the Japanese
initially collaborated with them but
then develops insurgencies afterwards
once they experienced boom I was
wondering how much you account for these
differences my friend I can't call out a
question but first of all your latter
statement is I'm afraid not true there
were resistance movements not only the
Philippines but particularly after all
what happened in Indochina what happened
in Burma the resistance movements pretty
well throughout Asia certainly in all of
Southeast Asia and the movement end and
then Denisha was try to start out being
poor Japanese and didn't work but out
with your permission I'm going to go
into this in my next talk where I talk
about the influence of the spread of the
of dominoes and what that's done to the
thinking about world strategy and but I
don't mean to brush over you repeat for
me your first comment if you will I was
referring to the the amount of variance
within American soldiers example thank
you you set up a you have American
soldiers rooted in in Hermann göring's
very cynical take on so I was wondering
how much variance you accounted for in
that group as well my point about the
American soldiers was not that there
were evil in any sense but that they
were caught in a situation that they
couldn't understand they couldn't deal
with it and were frightened and you can
see that an insurgency after insurgency
I was for example in Palestine in 1946
and a British soldier jammed the machine
gun in my stomach and and cursed me is a
dirty Jew I'd happened not to be Jewish
but didn't bother him at all but he was
scared because he'd been shot at and
other things that happened to him and
fear is a great shaper of all of our
lives and therefore one of the things
that I want to emphasize and and our
meeting together is that a big part of
our task is to reduce the level of fear
in the in the world that we don't really
have a lot of time to or a lot of
capacity if we are locked into fearsome
lists or fearless fearsomeness and I
think that they're what we need to ask
you to bear with me till I get my whole
message out and I think you'll see that
we're not too far apart on
yes sir I'm Paul Kennedy I'm in the
history department and I of course it's
difficult for us to pose questions to
you with on lecture one when there's the
other two to come and maybe the answer
to our questions is is coming in in your
text in the next two lectures next week
but it seemed to me from the text of
what you've given us today there is this
big anomaly which you just admitted in
response to the first question if you
remember that big anomaly is the United
States entering the second world war
you've made constant reference by person
for words between atrocity happenings
these are the American Indians in the
17th and 18th century an atrocity
happenings happening in different parts
of this world of ours and in the 20th
century in different parts of Africa and
different parts of Chechnya etc but and
then when you suggest this or teleology
or patent of this the white man's burden
not being this understood and therefore
leading to these these encounters which
which are bloody and inquisitive but a
sort of criticism I'm sort of words you
use near the very end of your fine first
lecture could it seem to me have been
given by any isolationist or
internationalists in this country right
not 1936 I'm 38 mm-hmm well be for
heaven's sake can't we learn a lesson
from all of that and keep away from it
does not do it again and then something
happens which is that they are greater
tyrannies more threatening powers
challenges and tax upon Pearl Harbor
knowledge of what the Nazis are doing
and their threat to democracy all over
the world shall we come in and for that
particular war the greatest we fight
yeah
has to be a different explanation and a
categorization of decisions on war and
peace and intentions then I think you're
giving either for the American settlers
towards the Indians or towards other
20th century colonial encounters so
we're in your next two lectures are you
going to fit in the story of the United
States in the world in the second world
war in the third may be war profiteering
I'm dealing think of everything going on
in this culture that may have such a
strong influence on the psychological
factors both mr. Kennedy's remarks and
yours raised the problem that I faced
and trying to boil my message down into
three short talks the I do deal to some
degree also in the third talk with what
you're asking of but stick around and
try okay
[Applause]
[Music]